hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan thank you
for joining me today I'm going to answer
question from one of my readers Allison
who asked me what the secrets of true
entrepreneur success is so that's a
bundle of a question I'll try to narrow
it down and keep this video pretty short
I'm going to share three things with you
that hopefully can help Alison and
everybody else is watching the first is
you got to start with the why so you
want to start a business that you're
really passionate about something that
you care deeply about and you feel you
can be able to help other people with
too many entrepreneurs start a business
because they think they can make a lot
of money and making money as part of
running a business but it's not the
reason to be in business you should want
to start a business because you you're
able to help people you feel you can add
a lot of value and you're really
passionate about what you're doing if
you look at any successful famous
entrepreneur you'll see that they served
the business because they really had a
strong desire to change the way things
were done in their industry it wasn't
about making a lot of money now making
money comes but it's not the main focus
so if you're certain business just to
make money I look at starting something
else look for a way to turn whatever
you're really passionate about where you
feel can help people into a business the
second thing I would do is try to model
success and when I was first getting
started I didn't know anything I was 19
years old running in my first you know
real business and I was overwhelmed
scared didn't know what to do and I then
you know the discovery came that you
know I'm not the first guy to try to do
what I'm trying to do right now these
others who have gone before me and
success leaves clues so I started
looking at successful entrepreneurs
we're in my industry who I could model
and that got me excited gave me ideas
and it also showed me that a lot of
these guys they started with nothing
they just had an idea and they had to
overcome huge obstacles to get to you
know where they eventually got to so it
gives me motivation as well to keep
going and eventual is able to build that
company up and sell it so look at people
who are in your industry who have
related products or services that you
can you know you look up to look at
other entrepreneurs who might
famous and you respect for different
reasons even if they have nothing to do
with your business so if you really like
Oprah Winfrey or Richard Branson or
whoever it is read their stories and how
they got started and look up to them and
try to model some of the things that
they did and apply to your business so
by modeling success be able to take what
may have taken somebody else years and a
lot of trial and error to figure out and
implement that into your business really
quickly and hopefully not make all the
same mistakes that they did to kind of
get to where they are so I'm a huge fan
of Mahlon success and the last bit of
advice that I want to leave you with
today is the amount that you'll make and
that's what a lot of entrepreneurs are
eventually looking for it how much money
am I going to make the amount you're
going to make is going to come down to
how much value provide so if you want to
make more money you have to provide more
value so think about the customers that
you're targeting think of how you can
help them and try to think of extra way
so you can go above and beyond to really
solve their problems if you need to make
more money provide more value and it's
basically as simple as that running a
business the entrepreneurs make money in
proportion to how much value they
provide to their customers so don't look
for you know cheap ways out of just
trying to grab as much money as you can
it's a short-term strategy to really
build a long-term successful business
you have to be able to provide a lot of
value to your customers and the morning
value provide then we are you going to
get paid so hopefully that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up I always appreciate those when
I see them coming in and I'd love to
hear we have to think if you want to
leave a comment under the video so thank
you and stay tuned for next episode
you